and kampe so it'll be kampe against
Anderson km with a puck into the cane Zone
Anderson stares him down and makes the
save I think he forced that wide shot by being
patient quick little attempt to go backhand
forehand and Freddy read it quite well got the
first goal of the night let's see if he can get
the first goal of the shootout it's Brent Burns
looking to put Carolina up one- nothing in the
shootout he goes wide in on Copley and Copley
closes the door and makes the save on burns so
no goals yet in the shootout he tried to get him
moving think he had a little room but that might
have been The Lure technique cuz Copley seemed to
have a good idea that he was going to try to beat
him between the legs now Pierre Luke Dubois
drafted by Colum is played for Winnipeg now
with the kings in on Anderson he scores keeps it
low goes to far side and La has taken the lead
in the shootout on dubois's shootout marker such
a popular shootout location since his Inception
back in 2005 2006 halfway up on the blocker side
and here comes Tavo terrain as you called it ter
into the LA Zone teravan in backhand and Copley
stays with him and makes the Save the King lead
one to nothing table when he's had shootout
success and he's had plenty of it often times
it looks it seems like he gets more elevation in
the back hand that was a good challenging save
Copley went down his hands came forward well
Ani Kopitar has a chance to end it the Kane's
Captain the king's Captain with two goals here
tonight and the Kings up one- nothing in this
shootout Kopitar in on Anderson and he misses so
Carolina's got life La tried to go to the blocker
side on all three shootout attempts had success on
one of them don't know if that Grays the shaft of
Freddy stick and I like this decision to go with
AO se's can get some good vibes in the shootout
for Sebastian had a breakaway goal back in the
first period oh here comes AO with speed in on
Copley he'll stop waight back in for it oh my
goodness what a move Sebastian oh and we extend
the shootout that's a now and later benefit it
keeps this game alive he's your star up front
number 22 and to score that type of goal with
the game on the line now let's see if it gets
even bigger as this thing moves along what a
beauty fourth round of the shootout Here Comes
Kevin fiala 1-1 in the shootout fiala backs in
Anderson and Anderson might have gotten enough
to knock that one over the net or fiala just air
mailed it either way fiala comes up empty yeah
I figured uh right after that desperation save
from Freddy leaning back but maybe getting it
with the inside of the right skate I figured
Rod would go either slaven or Jarvis Jarvis I
still think is the most natural finisher on the
roster we'll see if he has that natural finish
now Jarvis in on Copley walks him in he loses the
handle on it right at the top of the crease and
Copley pounces on it so we go to round number
five of the shootout think he might have been
thinking about going high heat there with coply
leaning to the right to the glove side and then
C about a different angle couldn't gather it lost
control of the puck now Trevor Moore power play
goal tonight for La he comes into the cane Zone
on Anderson and he scores Upper 90 to the glove
hand beautiful finish for a guy that
scored a power play goal back in the
second period sounded like
it went ping off that high
bar now Marty NIS and it's his turn to keep this
going NES storming into the king Zone on Copley
for back in it scores oh beautiful forand shot as
NES went to the club side I think this is I mean
again it extends the game but I think NES has been
a little bit sluggish so far this year number 55
this is a big moment for him big moment couldn't
tell if the puck was on edge he extends the
shootout just like AO did see if he can get a stop
on Byfield from Freddy Here Comes Quinton Byfield
in on Anderson and Fred rck Anderson flashes the
leather catches that and will hang on now Carolina
with a chance to win this excellent glove position
on by field in front of him watches it right
into the twine second time in Carolina beautiful
transition feed on Lemieux's go let's see if
D'Angelo can end it sixth round Kony D'Angelo
close it out for Carolina walks in and cley makes
the save made Tony show his hand first like Freddy
just had a very good attacking glove so too
was the case here the blocker well in front of
him Carl grundstrom now attacking the puck taking
it in on Anderson and tries to glove hand and no
success as Frederick Anderson closes the door I
love it when your hands for a goenda lishment in
front of you attacking the puck on top of his
position on top of the crease our first look
at the shootout attempt fting as a hurricane
Here Comes Michael Bunning with a chance to
end it for Carolina Bunning in forand back hand
and that it goes off the post Copley might have
gotten a piece oh burning with the right idea yeah
they're Copley did a good job of getting out and
matching the speed I don't think there was any
daylight there glove gets the piece layer glove
mechanically right on top of that pad Here Comes
Philip Doo as he saunters his way in on Anderson
and Anderson uses the glove again they're
trying to go glove hand and Anderson having
none of it Mike there's no drift there's no drift
in the hands they're attacking makes a [Applause]
[Applause] Shay eighth round Carolina with a
chance to win it Shay in Copley gets a piece
and we move into the ninth top of the ninth
inning here in La surprised we haven't seen
slaven yet he's had shootout success BR Shay has
certainly had success in finding the back of the
net misfired on that one with faier getting the
opportunity here on Frederick Anderson he goes
wide cuts in on Anderson foreit Anderson gets a
piece and we go to the bottom of the ninth with
Carolina with a chance to close it out it's Jordan
martinook last time he was here he was coming off
a hattrick in St Louis last December and he scored
here too Jordan martinook with a chance to end
it for Carolina right down the middle of the ice
Martin in Cy back in he scores Jordan Martin with
a goal scorers goal Carolina wins it in the bottom
of the ninth in the shootout It's a 65 win for
Carolina don't you love when players come
in with a lot of speed I think Martin came
in with more speed than anybody else did in
any of the shootout attempts massive for AO
to extend it when the game was on the line
for Nate just to do the same thing it took
a while but he came in with a lot of speed
a little nice little pump fake to freeze the
[Music]
goenda just enough Freddy made some saves there